let me ask you about uh the war in
Ukraine why did Russia invade Ukraine on
February 24th
2022 what are some of the explanations
given and which do you find the most
convincing well clearly the conventional
wisdom is that Putin uh is principally
responsible Putin is an imperialist uh
he's an expansionist that's the
conventional thing
yeah yeah and the idea is that uh he he
uh is bent on creating a greater Russia
uh and even more so he's interested in
dominating Eastern Europe if not all of
Europe um and that Ukraine was the first
stop on the train line uh and what he
wanted to do was to conquer all of
Ukraine uh incorporated into a greater
Russia and then he would move on and
conquer other countries this is the
conventional wisdom my view is there is
no evidence uh let me emphasize zero
evidence to support that argument which
part that he would the imperialist part
the sense that he would he sought to
conquer all of Ukraine and move on and
Conquer there's no evidence he was
interested in conquering all of Ukraine
there was no interested there's no
evidence beforehand that he was in
coning conquering any of Ukraine and
there's no way that an army that
had 90,000 troops at the
most right could have conquered all of
Ukraine just impossible as I like to
emphasize when the Germans went into
Poland in
1939 uh and the Germans you want to
remember were only intent on Conquering
the Western half of Poland because the
Soviets uh who came in later that month
we're going to conquer the eastern half
of Poland so the Western half of Poland
is much smaller than Ukraine and the
Germans went in with 1.5 million troops
uh If U Vladimir Putin were bent on
conquering all of Ukraine he would have
needed at least two million troops I
would argue he' need three million
troops because not only do you need to
conquer the country you then have to
occupy it uh but the idea that 190,000
troops was sufficient for conquering uh
all of Ukraine is not a serious argument
furthermore he was not interested in
conquering Ukraine and that's why in
March 2022 this is immediately after the
war starts he is negotiating with
zalinski to end the war there are
serious
negotiations taking place in Istanbul
involving the Turks and naali Bennett
Who was the Israeli Prime Minister at
the time was deeply involved in
negotiating with both Putin and zalinski
to end the war well if he was interested
Putin in conquering all of Ukraine why
in God's name would he be negotiating
with zalinski to end the war and of
course what they were negotiating about
was NATO expansion into Ukraine which
was the principal cause of the war uh
people in the west don't want to hear
that AR argument because if it is true
which it is then the West is principally
responsible for this bloodbath that's
now taking place and of course the West
doesn't want to be principally
responsible it wants to blame Vladimir
Putin so we've invented this story out
of whole cloth that he is an aggressor
that he's the second coming of Adolf
Hitler and that what he did in Ukraine
was try to uh to conquer all of it and
he failed but uh with a little bit of
luck he probably would have conquered
all of it and he'd now be in the Baltic
states and eventually end up uh
dominating all of Eastern Europe as I
said I think there's no evidence to
support
this